we're extremely pleased to have with us
on alternative views today Arthur Kenoi
who is a professor of law currently at
Rutgers University in Newark New Jersey
Arthur is a veteran of many decades in
the civil rights movement is the vice
president of the Center for
Constitutional Rights he's a member of
the National Board of the rainbow
coalition his author of Rights on trial
the Odyssey of a people's lawyer and
he's a longtime member of the National
Lawyers Guild he's in town this week for
the National Lawyers Guild meeting in
Austin and he kindly enough has come
down to alternative views today and
we're going to talk to you about your
life and struggles yeah flying in here
to Austin to come to the guild
convention all the sudden what hit me
just between the no shoulders was the
recognition that I was coming down to
Texas and that struck inside of me the
whole recollection of what had happened
that morning in Washington in 1966 with
Texas was deeply involved in my being as
you put it strangled by the US Marshals
at the house on American Activities
Committee because what I then remembered
I closed my eyes on the plane and I was
reliving the whole moment I had been
working the last couple of years before
that in the deep south representing the
very courageous black people who were
organizing and fighting for their
elementary constitutional rights and I
was representing the Mississippi freedom
Democratic Party and the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee and
dr. King
and I was down in Mississippi 1966 when
I got a call from New York City and
someone got on the phone and said
they've just gotten a call from
California that eight young students at
Berkeley California who had engaged in
the most radical activity you can
imagine they had organized the
first anti-war committee in California
on the Berkeley campus and they had just
been served with subpoenas from the
house on American Activities Committee
to come to Washington to explain why
they were subversive agents of the
Russians and would I come up from
Mississippi and represent them because
they had heard about a lot of work that
I had been doing down in the South in
defense of the courageous people who
were fighting down there
and they said we need somebody like that
also so I go up to Washington and I
agree alright we'll do this and I meet
together with these young people from
Berkeley and what do they say to me
we're meeting later that evening a day
before the hearing was scheduled and
they said we've read about what you
folks have been doing in the deep south
the lawyers who are representing these
people you don't sit back and always be
on the defensive you take the offensive
you fight against the people who are
persecuting and discriminating against
the people we want you to do the same
thing here in Washington and I said what
do you mean and one of the young men
says my father in the 1950s was called
before the McCarthy Committee which was
the same type of committee as an
American Activities Committee and he
didn't know what to do he didn't want to
participate in their process so all he
did is he got up there and he said oh I
don't want to participate I'll just
plead the fifth amendment and so on and
what did Joe McCarthy do he came out
with this great phrase he put his finger
right at him and he said you are a fifth
than commie and so the young man says my
father was devastated he got home he was
fired from his job at the plant I don't
want to play that kind of defensive game
he says do something about it and that's
something that we as people's lawyers we
were always told and I'm told that still
today and yesterday by people who are
fighting for their elementary rights
against the system what did they say to
us they say words that I have never
forgotten they say do something and so
what did we discuss we decided to do
what we had been doing for the
courageous folks down in the south
we decided that we would take the
offensive and start a federal lawsuit
against the unamerican Activities
Committee charging them with being
totally unconstitutional violating every
provision of the Bill of Rights and we
charged a conspiracy on their part to
undermine the fundamental rights of the
young people of California and all the
young people throughout the country and
we wrote out this complaint that's late
that night went into a federal court and
then the wildest thing in the world
happened the federal judge looks at it
and he says you making an argument here
I'll give you a temporary injunction
against the unamerican Activities
Committee for the hold on a hearing and
then he says have you got a draft of the
of an injunction for me and my heart
sank
it's never dreamt that we would have the
opportunity to when that DRI hadn't
prepared a draft and then this young
woman from one of the law schools and
thank the Lord for law students because
they save you all the time she comes up
to me and she'd been working with me and
she said Arthur I drafted through one of
these temporary restraining orders
just in case we were gonna win and I
give it to the federal judge he signs it
and then there headlines all over the
country on American Activities Committee
enjoined as unconstitutional and then of
course what happens late that night the
Court of Appeals has a he
at 4:00 in the morning in which the
government and the Department of Justice
had come in and said oh you can't do
that that's impossible so the Court of
Appeal says all right we won't have a
temporary restraining order but they
make a strong point we'll hear their
complaint later on so we're going to go
ahead with the hearing we're feeling
good and Norman short of it what happens
we go into the hearing and who is the
chairperson and some of you folks here
in Texas may remember him Joe Poole Joe
proof Jo poore was a congress
representative from Texas one of the
most conservative representatives of the
old white power structure in the south
and he's sitting there and what do they
do first thing they do is all of our
young folks are there they represented
for the committee the country with many
calls then what they know as and
everybody in the country's gotta learn
this word a friendly witness now that
doesn't mean friendly to you
that means friendly to the government
here and to you ACK and the friendly
witness gets up there and what does he
say great detail oh I know that these
are all agents of the Soviets these
young people they're getting paid by the
Russians and I could see our clients two
young people look at each other my god
and the one thing they don't have is
anybody you know they've never had they
had to borrow to even get to Washington
and then they he finishes and so what do
I do I'm a lawyer I get up and I say all
right I want to cross-examine this
witness and what does Joe Poole say you
have no right to cross-examine this is
the correctional committee sit down and
I can't tell your pet and I get up there
and I say wait a moment I have a right
under the Constitution in the United
States to represent these young people
and to cross-examine otherwise there is
not due process of law and he says
you know what you doing he says you're
arguing with me and what I say to him my
lord what is the lawyer supposed to do
and then he waves his hand and four
federal marshals from the back of the
hearing room brush up grabbed me by the
neck and dragged me out and I can still
feel her fingers on the throat and as
I'm going out I say something that
everybody have kidded me about for years
and years thereafter
the words that gasps out of me I say the
pool you can't do this to me I'm a
lawyer and they dragged me out and then
a friend of mine who had met in the old
days in the South several years before
from the new york times rushes up to me
and says to me i thought don't you
understand why this happened I should
know I don't instinct and he says nobody
steals headlines from Joe Poole
you got those headlines in your action
against him he was furious and he was
bound to get you and then I'm dragged
out in the carburetor and what they're 5
Capitol Police standing there and I'm
arrested and what am i arrested for I'm
arrested for a violation of a statute
they had in the District of Columbia in
those days saying that you're guilty of
disorderly conduct for using loud and
boisterous language in front of a
congressional committee and I'm arrested
and then dragged down and fight that out
in the next morning 54 lawyers from all
of the country from all the people's
organizations the civil rights of this
show up to represent me and then these
pictures of me being strangled appear on
the front page of almost every newspaper
in the country you're upstairs Joe pool
yeah exactly and then going short of it
what happens
the Court of Appeals I'm found guilty by
the local judge and the Court of Appeals
his income being says nonsense a lawyer
has not only the right but the duty to
stand up to represent his clients they
reversed the conviction and then this is
late 1966 our whole movement starts in
the country in which not only the folks
in the anti-war movement but people in
the growing women's movement people in
the American movement all come together
and say that the unamerican activity
committee is the most dangerous
instrument against the rights of the
people it's got to go and a movement
starts from one end of the country to
the other to abolish the unamerican
Activities Committee and then what
happens in 1973 we get a majority in the
House of Representatives and they vote
to abolish your American Activities
Committee and we have a great party that
night I've learned one thing the whole
fight that people whose rights were the
most important moments in fighting for
people's rights are the parties you have
hunter and self victory celebrations and
we're celebrating and my old friend from
the New York Times is there and he comes
up to me and he says Arthur you got to
realize one thing the picture of you
being strangled and pulled out of hue
act by those marshals did more to help
the abolition of that committee than any
brief you ever wrote that any legal
argument you ever made they looked at me
he said you got to learn one thing the
one thing the people of this country
cannot stand
it's the sight of a little person being
strangled and beaten up by big people
that's a long way round to say that that
was the fight and what we learned out of
it though was something that has a
terrific impact on our work today and
that is that if you're going to fight
for the rights of the people for the
protection of elementary constitutional
rights
you cannot sit quietly on the defensive
and just wait until they attack this
person and that person and then you go
through long torturous cases you have to
think through together with your clients
the people who are injured and hurt how
to take the offensive how to utilize the
legal system to say to the entire nation
that there is a danger to the rights of
all of us by what's going on and
charging that the administration the
Department of Justice or the local
police who are ever responsible for this
that they must be the defendants because
they are guilty of what they are guilty
of the most serious crime conspiracy to
undermine and destroy the Constitution
of the United States and that's the
lesson that I learned out of the work in
the 1950s against the McCarthy period in
the 1960s against the effort to destroy
black movement and the young people's
movement in the women's movement and the
experiences in the struggles that we had
in the 50s and 60s against the effort to
destroy the trade unions that you cannot
sit back quietly you have to fight back
you have been in the middle of all these
fights for so many years where do you
think we are now we've a lot of people
have been concerned about civil
liberties and they're the reagan-bush
administration's and a lot of the plans
that they have you think thinks or you
think the things are getting worse or
better I think that we are facing and
I'll put it very bluntly and I say this
from one end of the country to the other
we are facing the most serious
constitutional crisis that this country
has faced since the Civil War
and what is happening is a conscious
plan by the most powerful forces
in the governmental structure in the
industrial structure to experiment with
the undermining and abandonment of the
most elementary constitutional rights of
all of the people set forth in the
Constitution and that developed from the
earliest days the Reagan administration
one of the sharpest examples is the open
plan to undermine Barry and then totally
paralyzed all of the statutes which had
been passed in the 1960s guaranteeing
the civil rights of I don't need after
American people not only people of color
but women poor white people older people
the 1964 Civil Rights Act the 1965
Voting Rights Act which had been passed
why because millions of people in this
country had organized and demanded that
rights that they had been denied for
hundreds of years must be enforced all
right we want on that and we got
wonderful ways of going into the federal
courts to protect people who were
discriminated against in employment
discriminated against in any aspect of
life and what did from the first days of
the Reagan administration what was
announced that these the decisions of
the Supreme Court were told enforcing
these statutes were totally without any
right whatsoever and William Bradford
Reynolds sounds like ancient history
most people don't even remember his name
but he was assistant attorney general in
charge of civil rights and friends of
mine on Capitol Hill in the middle of
the 80s they grabbed me into their
office once they said with a straight
face Arthur we're going to put a
resolution on the floor of Congress to
change
William Bradford Reynolds title we're
going to call them the sister
the general in charge of burying civil
rights and what was the position that he
put forward that there is no
constitutional or statutory authority in
this country to enforce group rights you
cannot have any remedy where women are
discriminated against in a factory for
example you cannot have a remedy which
says the canape discrimination against
women we're black people you cannot have
a remedy where unions are discriminated
against union members you can't have a
remedy saying they are entitled to group
relief and what was this this was an
effort to totally bury the civil rights
statutes which were designed to what to
give protection to the constitute the
meaning of the amendments passed after
the Civil War the 13th 14th 15th
amendments they were passed for the
purpose of protecting the group rights
of not only the emancipated black people
from slavery but as the people who wrote
the amendment said to protect every
class of people in this country who ever
have a badge of inferiority placed upon
them and that is in the Constitution
United States in the statute surpassed
and the regular administration position
was we got to get rid of this and what
was it I have to explain to folks all
over the country who because don't
remember our American history and I have
to say this I'm very disturbed sometimes
at the fact that there is not sufficient
studying of the lessons of our American
history these that these amendments were
passed and these statutes has passed to
guarantee the protection of millions of
people throughout the country and then
what happens in 1877 you have what goes
down in history known as the Hayes
tooten compromise in which what in which
there was agreement between the northern
Republicans and the defeated southern
slave owners not the new governments the
south
that there would be no enforcement
whatsoever of the wartime amendments and
then what for 17 years there was no
protection whatsoever for the
constitutional rights of not only the
black people but any oppressed person in
the country and then it's changed when
we're facing the same situation because
what happened last June in the Supreme
Court of the United States where Reagan
over what ten years had been able to
appoint a handful of extremely
conservative justices who then had a
majority they came down with sweeping
decisions which had the same effect as
the 1877 betrayal which came down with
legal gobbledygook and I use that phrase
you know why because we lawyers have a
tendency and judges to use words that
nobody understands why because over the
long years and I say this in that
self-critical way our profession the
legal profession uses terms so that
people will not understand what we're
doing and then what happened was these
decisions came down one after another
totally tying up the hands of the
enforcement of the most elementary
rights not to be discriminated against
on the part of women on the part of
older people and the part of black
people Latino people Mexican American
people's young people Native American
Native American people's and then what
has happened and this is a terribly
important thing for us everybody in the
country to know some of the members of
Congress just recently introduced a bill
into the Senate into the house known as
the Kennedy Hawkinsville the 1990 civil
rights statute which was designed to
overcome these decisions and to restore
the elementary constitutional rights of
millions and millions of people the
protection against any form of
discrimination and the bill is now in
the Senate and
house and what is happening Thornburg
the Attorney General of the United
States just six weeks ago publicly
stated that he has advised Bush the
President to veto the bill if it is
passed and tremendous amount of lobbying
is going on on the part of the biggest
corporations in the country who feared
this bill because it's saying you can't
discriminate against people and if you
do you're going to have to pay damages
you have to pay fines and the
corporation's don't want this and they
take the position we have the right to
do anything we please Arthur let's go
back a step before we go into this bill
in more detail why would the Reagan and
Bush administration undertake a
systematic assault on civil liberties
doing some of the things that you've
just described and opposing bills like
this at Kennedy Hopkins bill is it
simply because they're in the hands of
corporations and are simply carrying out
the policies of the wishes of different
corporations or why would a government
be against civil liberties it's hard to
imagine that they would have solved you
know our very Constitution our very
basic liberties see it cuts even deeper
than that
because what's involved the difference
between the old 1877 and the new 1877 is
that this is not just an attack on the
constitutional protections of the rights
the Mansa pated people whose end up the
peoples of color this is an attack on
every single constitutional right of
every person the right not to be have
your home broken into the right not to
be stopped on a highway and searched and
frisked without a warrant the violation
is the Fourth Amendment the protections
of the First Amendment the protections
of the right to counsel
they have conscious effort to weaken and
undermine every one of these rights and
what is beginning to develop
and people were beginning to see this
the power structure not only in the
government but in the big corporations
they are very frightened and what are
they frightened at that millions and
millions of people in this country are
angry and suffering from the most
elementary problems that they have which
are not being solved women with shocking
examples and I'm sure you have some of
this down here in Texas I've been at
many meetings all through the Midwest of
whom the family farmers hundreds of
thousands family farmers are facing what
the worst crisis in their lives the farm
mortgage foreclosure crisis in which the
big banks are coming in and they're open
about it they've decided that we don't
need family farms any longer in this
country that we must have what is known
as what corporate agriculture and they
will be destroyed all right
the family farmers and we must
understand this they are not long-haired
radicals they are what what we've always
known as the heart of middle America and
what are they saying they're in meetings
all over they are furious and why
because they want they went to the White
House they demanded what what their
grandparents got from a certain
president known as Franklin Roosevelt
the first thing nah I think I was a
youngster at that time I didn't even
remember this but I'll never forget an
older farmer saying this to me at the
meeting in Kansas that his father had
told him that the first thing that
Franklin most voted done when he was
elected was to sign a presidential
decree declaring a four-year moratorium
on farm foreclosures giving the family
farmers a chance to
and they were saved all right they went
to Washington during the Reagan period
and then again the first this year the
Bush administration and you know what
they were told by Reagan and Bush go
home we don't have any right to
interfere with banks we don't have any
right we don't have any power to do this
so the family farmers are furious and
what are they looking for for the first
time they want to work together with
what millions of people and many of them
across the state line from them who are
facing what the crisis of plant closings
hundreds of thousands millions of
American people workers working people
and many of them white working people
many of them people our color our face
with devastation I don't have to tell
you folks down there you take a look you
go into anywhere along the Ohio River
for example where the steel plants were
first developed and you go into some of
these cities and what does it look like
London looked like after the bombings in
World War two because the plants are all
closed down and the business people the
small business people are destroyed
there's no market and they're furious
and they're trying to come together in
what are they demanding very elementary
demand if these companies closed our
plants we must have the right to run
them ourselves we must have the right to
take them over and the state of
Pennsylvania as a result of this
pressure from the majority of its people
passed a bill setting up a plant closing
agency that had the power under again
our technical legal word that nobody
understands called eminent domain coming
from we're coming from the Middle Ages
in England that a town has the power to
take over property which injures the
interests of the people of the town and
we want to take a look and what are the
big corporations doing they're going
into court and they're charging that
what this is Bolshevism this is
unamerican we have the right not only to
own a plan to close a plant
period alright so the plant the family
farmers are saying we can't win by
ourselves it's true the plant closing
people can't win by themselves the
working people the union people but if
we get together reinforcing trance and
then what are they saying we want to get
together and they've asked for meetings
now and this is making American history
meetings with representatives of the
black movements all through the south or
facing as folks all through the South
know almost homelessness property and
redistricting losing the right to vote
then you take in the urban areas to the
north what's the most serious problems I
don't know where do you have it down
here drug housing housing homelessness
and then the drug crisis from one end of
the country to the other so people
getting together take the women's
movements women the furious because what
the same Supreme Court in June came down
with a decision which put the knife in
to what had been decided in Roe against
Wade as the fundamental right of women
to make decisions over their own lives
their own bodies the right to abortion
and so the women saying we've got to do
something about this and not only threat
to abortion the right of women not to
have sexual harassment in the job which
I don't have to tell you folks that's
one of the most current phenomena in our
society that women have this experience
in factories at unemployment everything
else so if you add together all of these
groups and they unite to fight for what
all kinds of radical changes nonsense to
fight for their immediate survival
survival what will that mean and the
folks in the power structure the
industrial military complex and that's
not a radical term you know who that was
for eisenhower first use that term
alright if all these folks come together
and fight for their immediate needs then
the power of the industrial military
complex is
and will ever change we have a new type
of government a new type of government
representing the needs and interests of
the people and the power structure is
scared to death about this and that's
why they are saying that why do these
people do they'll use these elementary
constitutional rights to organize their
use it to come together they use it to
fight for their rights there for a
moment has come when we have to get rid
of these rights and what are they
putting forward and I lived through this
in the Nexen period because I was thrown
right into this fight in the Supreme
Court of the United States little
concept known as what the inherent power
of the President of the United States to
suspend the Constitution or any
provisions thereof or any laws of the
government when he decides it's in the
national interest to do so and they're
putting that forward once again well
there isn't this already in the books
and the McCarran act that the president
can declare an emergency and start
putting people in concentration camps so
it's not directly in the McCarran act
but they are trying to read the McCarran
act is saying that but what they are
doing see they came
you will remember folks like us who were
not just you know young people will
remember in the Nixon period ancient
history Richard Nixon came forward with
what with the position that the
President had the power to engage in
warrantless wiretapping without
considering the requirements of the
Fourth Amendment that you have to have a
warrant to engage in wiretapping and
what was the thesis that they put
forward the thesis was the president can
decide whenever he it is necessary that
he can suspend the provisions of the
Constitution and I was asked the last
minute to come in take this case that
involved young people in Detroit who
were warrantless ly wiretap to the
Supreme Court and we argued that out
and the Supreme Court itself which in
those days was considered once remember
what used to be called the mixin Court
thus they were conservative justices
Chief Justice burger had taken over from
justice Warren but when we've laid it on
the line that what was involved here was
the essence of Americanism that this
country from the revolution on was built
under the concept that this is what this
is a government of limited powers
governed by the written constitution
which was written by home and I reminded
the court something that as a youngster
I've been taught something that Thomas
Jefferson used to say that there are not
three branches of the government the
legislature the judiciary in the
president there are four branches and
the fourth branch is supreme in the
fourth branch of the people and the
Constitution was written to protect the
people and what happens is conservative
court says you're right but now we have
the Reagan Bush administration's ruler
FEMA setting up additional concentration
camps and martial law provisions
provisions exactly and that's the crisis
we face now that's their response to
these turmoils of the people their eggs
are the faculty here and what they are
doing now is they are reacting with an
abandonment of the elementary principles
of the Constitution and replacing it by
what let's face it
what are they replacing it by they're
replacing it by total totalitarian rule
of the master up there so it gives the
president totalitarian powers to suspend
the Constitution to violate anyone's
right whenever the president deems it's
necessary and what I discovered a lot of
people throughout the country don't know
is that Reagan and Bush sent all of the
north to FEMA the Federal Emergency
Management Agency to do a memorandum as
to what they should do in case of an
emergency where I mean where a lot of
people in this country would not agree
with their engaging in military
activities I can envision like an
invasion or anywhere in the world and
what's do and he writes out and this was
in as you know the Miami Herald during
the Iraq Contra hearings July 1st 1987
that the president should issue an order
and in so many words and when I saw that
for the first time I couldn't believe it
suspending the Constitution United
States suspending the Congress and
replacing it with a military government
suspending local and state legislatures
suspending the courts and replacing with
military tribunals and establishing
detention camps throughout the country
in which any person who didn't agree
with this Proclamation would be thrown
in and this is what and that memorandum
as far as we know is still sitting on
bush's desk and yet nobody except i'm so
pleased to hear that you folks in this
channel have been discussing this
because the media had you know media and
in evidence of these threats to civil
liberties on the mainstream media and
what's even worse it isn't just a
decision of the President they've
delegated that they have provisions to
delegate this authority to local
commanders and police authorities so
that they can suspend civil liberties on
a local basis but whenever they want to
and I will never forget something that
when I was once thousand years ago a
youngster a young student we were in a
room and we were coming together to talk
out what were we gonna do this was in
the mid 30s what were we going to do as
students to try to fight for our rights
and an older person he was at 23 years
old came into our room and said
something that I have never forgotten he
said you must never forget something
that that greatest student of
totalitarianism in this country just
said last night and who is he referring
to Huey Long the then governor of
Louisiana and what did he tell us Huey
Long had said the day before what the
American people must never
get is that when fascism comes to
America it will come wrapped in an
American flag and that's something that
I have never forgotten because that's
the problem that we face today we have
to be very open about this what are we
facing we're facing the road to fascism
and when we understand that millions and
millions of American people will stand
up and will fight for the elementary
preservation of the American system of
government yes they're the unamerican
we're the Conservatives we have fighting
something civil liberties and the car
agency cetera and when we understand
that and we discuss this and I find that
when I discuss this with folks with high
school students with college students
with folks and unions and community
organizations they haven't heard any of
this but when they hear it they ready to
move and they want to move it seems like
the sort of lesson of your life is that
if we don't struggle for our elementary
civil liberties we're allowing the road
to fascism to take place in our lifetime
and those of us that want to prevent
fascism or repressive government from
achieving hegemony in the United States
have to fight for these civil liberties
and Arthur you fought for these for
decades and we can only applaud admire
your heroic struggles on behalf of our
civil liberties so thank you for coming
and thank you for existing and I can say
that it was been exciting for me to have
been down here in Austin the last two
days at the guild convention where so
many students from the University of
Texas were there and in an excited way
we're discussing what they have to do in
order to fight for these elementary
rights so there is some hope out there
great hope